what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
super excited because right now I'm
standing in Derbyshire and I'm viewing a
house that was bought by a guy called
Liam age 19. he bought this house to do
it up and to sell it he used bridging
Finance he used the angel investor and
he's going to make a clean profit of 80
000 pounds and in this video we're going
to meet Liam we're gonna go around the
house he's gonna tell you exactly how he
structured it and how you can do the
same thing too let's go
oh
[Music]
Liam Taylor how are you doing dude this
place is amazing I think the views I
couldn't believe when I was driving up I
was just like wow yours is like right at
the very top the Pinnacle one thing you
can't change about the house the views
right location location I'm sure there
was a lot of things you had to change on
the inside yeah definitely spent a few
pennies in there she's gonna sell it yep
sell it what was it that made you decide
not to keep because this would work as a
holiday though bro see I am on the verge
of piano as I say I want to go into
development you see so that 80 gun
profit will go down nicely to kind of
set me up yeah you want to make that
chunk of cash yeah that's it Way Forward
dude no snap options though yeah that's
it yeah show me around take us around
good stuff bro well done
oh beautiful mate cheers man we love
this and you know what as well again
even in the house the views got the
views cook it and it makes me feel like
I want to cook cooking in the kitchen
with a view like that where did you get
this uh this new kitchen from went to
howdens got the drawings all drawn up it
just ripped everything out basically so
was there a crappy kitchen here before
oh it's Dreadful yeah very Dreadful
Windows all had lead lining on them so
all them have been changed now and I've
had to have two kitchen Fitters for this
because the first one went off to
Thailand just unless the other wanted a
bit of a mess I've had a bit of a
problem with the kitchen yeah but apart
from that it's all gone it's all gone
smoothly have interest how much was this
kitchen it was a house kitchen how much
did you have to pay for it yeah I think
including all the appliances and
everything it was about foreground and
you've done the reefer quick yeah almost
finished now yeah just turned 20. that's
it and when you bought this property you
were you bought it a few months ago you
were 19. yeah that's it yeah yeah 19
yeah and you've owned a big nice
beautiful house with views like this how
does it how does it feel oh amazing yeah
really good most people are 36 before
they own a house like this you bought a
house like this at 19. so biggest
question I think people might be
thinking that are watching this
especially if they're like 19 is how the
heck do you afford the refurb
the house in the first place like how
did you afford to buy it and do it up
well I've got an investor an engine
investor and bridging Finance but the
engine investor gave me 80 grand it was
initially 100 Grand but you couldn't
quite get that last 20 over the line
from his retirement fund so 80 grand 10
back within six months and then also his
parenting Clauses after that yeah and
then we've got bridging Finance to cover
the rest and then I've put some of my
own money in how did you at 19 manage to
get an investor to drop 80 000 pounds
into your company how did they have the
confidence in you it's the way you speak
to investors I personally feel so I had
to put my best foot forward and I just
told them everything I've done in the
past my other businesses what's your
other businesses I've got a flooring
business as well yeah and how old were
you when you set that up 17. there's a
huge respect man so you're able to show
him a lot I'm a business owner yeah I've
got a flooring business look at the work
that I do I'm professional where did you
find the investor from how did you get
into contact which was through the
academy when we have a champagne
um dinner thing nice and I think Ricky
actually had us going around in a circle
speaking to everybody and I managed to
speak to the investor and I've told him
what I wanted and what they wanted
trying to help them out with their
problems
um and I just said I'm looking for an
arrest for this deal I've got and she
said yeah I'm happy to happy to invest
in you but we'll I'll think about it and
I'll go speak to my dad about it I met
up with them pair in Birmingham just in
a pub
got all my numbers up got everything
together got photos up got all the deal
like packaged in a way I said look this
is the deal if you want to invest this
is where it's at really
um I showed him my previous work from my
flooring just to show them up to top
standard and all that kind of stuff and
he just says yeah I'm happy where do I
send the money to exactly and again like
when you invest in yourself
people invest in you I think the hardest
bit about property is not getting the
money everyone thinks oh I haven't got
any money the hardest bit is having the
skills to get the deals like this like
you come out and you found the deal and
because you have the deal the investor
the bridging company because they can
see that you'd found a good deal that's
why they were happy to back it yeah
that's it it's like there's a proxy down
the road as well that the estate agents
brought to me because I bought this one
off them they've pitched it to me and
I'm trying again it's just a sale on it
currently and it's just going through
and it's off market and that's off
Market as well yeah so hopefully and
it's on the same street yeah so fingers
crossed and fingers as well like
everyone wants them everyone's like oh
give me money help me this but unless
you can prove to people that you're
serious yeah like you buying this house
now the estate agent knows you're a
serious buyer treats you like a serious
buyer don't matter about your age the
marketplace doesn't discriminate it
matters about your value you can bring
and what you're doing in business yeah
exactly yeah and you've become a serious
player man that's it if you I bet it
took you a long time to find a deal like
this uh yeah I've went here I went to
probably 50 viewings probably sold a
couple of deals yeah
um how much did you make selling deals
nine grand yeah okay yeah that's almost
your Academy back yeah exactly yeah and
then you found this deal and you thought
it's too good to sell yeah basically
it's too close to home so yeah you're
good to sell so I thought I'll try and
get an investor so I'll put my offer in
for you even had the investors I thought
if I'm on the edge I'll uh I'll
definitely push myself to get one yeah
so I'll probably about a week off the
estate agent telling me that they set
like the sellers dropped out because
being too slow but I've managed to get
there in the end yeah and here we are
dude I love it yeah
[Music]
so what's the story then in here what
did you have to do
uh full strip back basically pretty much
back to Brick really everything yeah put
the spotlights in new flooring skirts or
doors yeah
um but this fireplace was in already so
I chose to keep it as like a little
feature kind of thing yeah so how it
looked before to how it looks now I mean
how much have you had to spend on the
entire house to get it looking like this
so far
um I've spent 20 grand on it that's
including all council tax everything but
I reckon I'm gonna end up spending about
22 just to finish it off because the
little bits here and there add up don't
they
um but it's just the finishing off like
the painting and stuff you've got a
project managed it yourself yes yeah so
you've been pretty Hands-On where do you
live how far away do you live from there
yeah I live about 10 to 15 minutes away
yeah so it's not too bad so you spent
about 20 grand maybe 22 once you've
finished it including the council tax
and all the different things you had to
pay so question is how much do you pay
for the house uh 194
650. tell me the story so it was on the
market for 260 originally and then it
dropped down to 240 then 220 and then
um I saw it on there at 220 so I said
I'll come around and have a look but
yeah it looked around it it was perfect
it was just like a Granny's house
basically you just needed that uplift
it's all loads of furniture everywhere I
thought I kind of knew how much money it
needed to bring it up to standard yeah
um so I initially offered 190 on the
property and they said no look that's
two like it's cash off forward bridging
and stuff
um so I came back to him said I'll give
you 194 650 and it just basically said
to me
the kind of large screams I said I'll
clear all the furniture out as well I'll
do this I'll do that and then they
finally said yes we'll take it and I was
over the moon
you know I'm so glad about that but they
wanted 220 as a minimum you offered 190
and they said no
you came back if you come back and said
200 that have got me in the middle I
know we said 222.10 but you came back
and said 194 650 which is so specific
but even better than that as you said
1946.50 why did you offer that figure
exactly by the way well I just from your
training you said offer specific numbers
exactly because if you say one nine four
six fifty it's so specific it sounds
like you've literally gone through your
bank sold your jewelry like that is the
last penny but then even clever than
that as you said and I'll clear out the
house because it sounds like literally
you're just like you've rinsed me yeah
you've rinsed me they accepted it you
bought it for one nine four six fifty
spend 20 grand doing it up and now
you're selling it what's it what's the
value now the value is roughly about 300
to 325. no that's from a um estate
agent's valuation as well so 80 grand
that's not that's not the profit in the
deal that's the profit you're gonna get
yes correct
okay show me the rest of the house
yeah so it's two bedroom house and we've
pretty much done everything in both the
rooms so you see carpets now yeah
carpets down and then it's a wrap that's
it nice Garden in the back spotlight's
gone in about to put this back to Brick
and so it's been re-plasted skirts arcs
everything I think you've done well for
just 22 grams yeah exactly because 22
Grand that's once the carpets are doing
everything uh yes yeah it is it's not
bad I know you've done you project
managed it yourself yeah I managed to
negotiate some things down there like at
hardens and managed to get somebody off
the doors and stuff yeah can I use staff
discounts and stuff like that but
um same again in this room spotlights
back to break plasters Arc skirts and
being a two bedroom is good because for
service accommodation you're going to
maximize your monthly profit yeah well
if you were going to do that but you're
not planning on doing it as a holiday
there no but I can never refinance it
that's another option so on this build
I've got multiple options I can do this
so it's like an exit strategy yeah
pretty much and the thing is as well if
you refinanced it your mortgage payments
would be quite hard because interest
rates have gone up but if you do it as a
holiday it'll override that muscle do
you ever get tempted to just eliminate
yourself
I do my girlfriend's all about that she
wanted to knock through that wall have a
nice big walking wardrobe and put his
formula it's not feeling so I kind of
want to I still want to sell it or
refinance it I'm not quite excited yet I
think refinancing is a good exit
strategy yeah if you can't set it yeah
how much you're gonna try and sell it
for uh I think I'm gonna put it on at
three two five and just start off high
yeah and then and then somewhere between
then 300 yeah I'll happily take I'll
happily take for it if you did refinance
it what would that look like uh pull on
the horny out straight away would you be
able to pay all your bridging off your
investors off yeah pay them all their
interests yeah or their interests will
be gone
for an essay won't be mad with it it
wouldn't be bad Ideal World why don't
you just do that why did you want to
sell it so badly because I want that
money too it's the development or what I
want to buy multiple more to do up yeah
I just want to see that chunk of cash
yeah I'm not I've never really been
interested in essays or I'm an
interesting hmos if I own them oh I
started off with them trying to get
ready to rent some stuff and I was going
around in circles for ages right
um but I didn't rent friends to get you
that passive income so yeah just quit
your job well I already have a flooring
didn't I and I applied to working for me
you see so that's my passive income yeah
so doing this getting this chunk of cash
going into development it's perfect for
me so what why are you so determined to
try and sell it I want to see that cash
in my bank so I can then move on forward
to another project reinvest reinvest
reinvest yeah that's it yeah makes sense
I think the thing is there's no right or
wrong thing to do exactly and it also
depends on the way the market moves yeah
you always need exit strategies if
you're relying on selling it and then no
one buys it you're screwed yeah if
you're relying on refinancing yet but
then you forget to pay eBay Bill and
you've got bad credit you're screwed
like having multiple options I think
that's why the investor liked it as well
because there's multiple exit strategies
yeah so everyone we've always got a
backup always have an exit strategy
multiple plans plan a plan B plan C exit
strategy two the exit strategy
nice love this bathroom yeah my favorite
room in the house did you have to tile
this yourself yes did you physically do
it yourself yes I did that what I did
these respect and then my mate did that
one you know did you want a lot of your
friends then I did yeah I mean why did
you do that uh because I wanted to pay
them rather than pencil and random I'd
happily playing my mates because I'd
rather give them the cash rather than
somebody who I don't know yeah um and I
mean they've done done a good job and I
can't really complain that's the thing
when you're a successful entrepreneur a
property investor you're also given the
people that you love your family your
friends work jobs opportunities yeah
that's incredible yeah great
what would you say has been like the
biggest
lesson through all of this the biggest
lessons that you've learned through
doing this finding deals if you find the
deal then the investor will come with it
yeah if it's a good enough deal anybody
will be happy to invest in it right yeah
bridging company yeah investor you can
sell it like you've sold some yeah
exactly uh well I made nine grand from
that so it's not it's not all a bad gig
really
um but yeah just a good deal good exit
strategies yeah
um investors like multiple exit
strategists because then they've got
something to rely on if one thing
doesn't work yeah and are you in the
process of getting a deal wrapped up you
mentioned how far is it from here oh and
like a minute walk down the road should
we go look at it in a minute yeah tell
me what the story is with it similar to
this one really uh it's an off-market
deal so it's straight to straight to the
estate agent it's brilliant I've got a
few investors in line before it but not
not directly yeah and just needs work
doing it similar to this so it's the
same story same story why are they so
motivated to sell it and get it for a
quick crash sale because I think the
owners have gone off to a uh care home
so she's in line with the kids now and
they don't want to deal with it
basically and so I'm trying to push it
off and the thing is when you're a cash
buyer exactly straight in you can you
can pay what you want you're a cash
buyer that's it yeah and even if you
don't have cash in your bank you can be
a cash buyer by bringing in bridging
finance companies investors yeah that's
huge amazing bro yeah you must be super
proud of yourself yeah definitely yeah
amazing was going to look at this next
property but in the meantime guys if you
found not useful drop a like drop a
comment my man Liam Taylor I'm gonna
leave his details in below in the
description if you want to connect if
you want to connect with myself I'm
running a one day property investors
crash course that's what it started for
you yeah definitely give me a second
about the crash course how was it crash
course really good but you only pay a
pound for it and I wouldn't take it back
and then from the crash course I went
straight to the academy and then I'll
never look back from that come on down
man it's one pound most people watching
this are just I don't know I'm not sure
you've got to get comfortable being
uncomfortable I'll leave a link in the
description connect let's do business
let's go look at this other house